jetzt sprechen wir über ein phänomenes
für großes Aufsehen sorgt am Wochenende
in den vergangenen Tagen gab es immer
wieder Flugobjekte einige wurden
abgeschossen über den USA über Kanada
Alaska viele Fragen wirkt das auf und es
ist ein Thema mit dem sie sich ja
Fleischer intensiv beschäftigen ein
Thema bei dem manche sofort anfangen zu
kichern und sagen ja hihihi jetzt reden
wir über piep piep aus dem All aber sie
fordern dass wir uns diesen Thema
endlich ernsthaft nähern uns ernsthafte
mit auseinandersetzen so wie sie sagen
das andere Regierungen auch machen ihre
Zeit ihre Kamera genau das wurde auch
nicht nur ich sondern das fordern auch
Soziologen deutsche Soziologen und
Rechtswissenschaftler die sagen wir sind
überhaupt nicht auf die Möglichkeit
vorbereitet das wird tatsächlich mal in
Kontakt kommen mit einer höher
entwickelten Spezies und so wie es
aussieht haben wir es mit so etwas zu
tun allerdings nicht aufgrund dieser
drei Objekte die in den USA jetzt
abgeschossen worden sind die zeigen eben
gerade nicht diese normalen
Eigenschaften die uaps wie sie heißen
ohne identifizierten an normalen
Phänomenen zugeschrieben werden und das
sind nämlich plötzliche Beschleunigung
hyperschallgeschwindigkeit ohne
Überschallknall geringe Beobachtbarkeit
transmedium Fortbewegung das heißt die
sind in der Lage aus dem Weltall in die
Atmosphäre und unter Wasser zu wechseln
und zurück ohne dass sie ihr
Flugverhalten ändern müssen allein das
ist sensationell und sie sind in der
Lage an der Stelle zu schweben ohne
sichtbare Auftrieb oder irgendwas und
sie verursachen zum Weinen auch
biologische Effekte bei Menschen so und
man muss dazu sagen diese Objekte die
sind mit dem Wind getrieben deswegen hat
das hat das US Militär die auch
überhaupt abschießen können denn ähm ich
muss sagen es wäre das allererste Mal
dass ich also ich habe noch nie davon
gehört dass es Militär es geschafft
hätte einen UFO wirklich abzuschießen es
gibt aber mehrere Fälle wo das versucht
worden ist und zwar im Iran 1976 da ist
ein Ufer über terrangebt kampfjetpilot
steigt auf wird dorthin geleitet und in
dem Moment wo er seine seitweine Rakete
aufschaltet fallen seine Bordinstrumente
aus er muss umkehren und verrichtete
Dinge das wiederholt sich mal es gibt
einen anderen Fall Brasilien mai 1986
13stündige sichtungswelle über den
großen Metropolen in Brasilien
mindestens 21
UFOs
riesengroße UFOs teilweise werden von
Kampfjets gejagt die allerdings kein
Erfolg haben weil diese Objekte den
ausweichen und denen dann folgen und
neben ihnen herfliegen laut den
freigegebenen militärunterlagen aus
Brasilien vom Militär und das Militär
denkt dass Intelligenz dahinter gesteckt
hat hinter diesen Objekten dasselbe in
Belgien 1989 90 bei drei Gelegenheiten
da gab es ja diese riesengroße
sichtungswelle mehr als 650 Sichtungen
mehr als ähm oder dreimal wurden F16
Kampfjets gestartet einmal haben die
schnelle Änderungen in Tempo und
Flughöhe registriert aber sie haben es
nicht geschafft diese Dinger
abzuschießen und der bekannteste Fall
ist ja erst 2004 von der Westküste der
USA passiert wo uaps um einen
Flugzeugträger rum geklebt sind und da
haben sie es auch nicht geschafft und
diese uaps sind plötzlich wie aus einer
Gewehrkugel geschossen sind haben sich
von diesem Ort entfernt und haben sich
interessanterweise an dem Ort dann
eingefunden wo die Kampfjets erst
hinfliegen sollten das nennen die den
capoint den Einsatzpunkt von wo aus dann
weiteres Einsatz Geschehen geplant wird
und das ist auch interessant weil man
sich fragen muss woher wusste das UAP
wohin die Kampfjets dann fliegen sollten
also kurz in 28 Ländern auf der Welt
haben Militärs
UFO Fälle dokumentiert schwerwiegende
UFO-Fälle teilweise es gibt in sieben
Ländern staatliche UFO
forschungsbehörden unter anderem in
unserem Nachbarland Frankreich da gibt's
das schon seit 1974 und in Amerika ist
Arrow jetzt gerade erst dazu gekommen
also Amerika ist sozusagen das new kid
on the block ja und warum machen die das
haben die nicht alle Untertassen im
Schrank oder warum werden warum nehmen
all diese Länder
UFOs so ernst und Deutschland kommt
nicht warum gibt es das in Deutschland
angeblich nicht also ich fasse das mal
zusammen und ich muss zugeben mir fällt
der Anja und an das Thema auch immer
noch schwer gleichzeitig denke ich wenn
man das Wunder der Welt begreift und
sieht was für ein Menschen sind muss man
vielleicht auch endlich mal den Blick
dafür öffnen und das hoffe ich dass wir
das hier an diesem Tisch auch
dementsprechend heute abend machen daher
jetzt die Frage an sie glauben also
wirklich das sozusagen eine Art erst
Kontakt bevorsteht oder dass wir den
schon längst erlebt haben und alle
anderen das Wissen und wir Deutschen
hoffen immer noch das ist doch irgendwie
nicht passiert oder wie kann ich das
verstehen
Piloten geredet ich habe auch mit
Geheimdienstlern geredet aus Amerika
unter anderem mit dem Leiter des
ehemaligen geheimen
ufo-forschungsprogramms und der sagt da
steckt definitiv eine Intelligenz
dahinter hinter diesen Objekten die die
dort interessant finden also ich muss
noch sagen 90% von dem was gemeldet wird
ist wirklich Ballons und so weiter und
so fort aber die wirklich interessanten
Fälle das sind dann die Rumänien die
letzten verbleibenden zehn bis fünf
Prozent der Fälle die sich vor allem
eben in der Nähe von militärischen
Anlagen abspielen und was sich auch raus
kristallisiert immer mehr ist dass diese
Objekte vermehrt in der Nähe von
militärisch sensiblen atoman Anlagen
gesichtet werden so hat das Phänomen
überhaupt das angefangen das zieht sich
wie ein roter Faden durch die UFO
Geschichte muss man sagen und das ist
was was die Militärs und die
Geheimdienste sehr sehr ernst nehmen und
bei denen besteht kein Zweifel daran
dass es sich hier um irgendwelche
hochtechnologischen Objekte handelt also
mit einer Technologie wo wir nicht mal
entfernt dran kommen hinter denen
irgendeine Art von Intelligenz steckt
und da will ich jetzt nicht sagen das
ist die Aliens sind weil ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob die außerirdische
Hypothese die beste ist denn die Dinger
werden ja hier ständig gesehen irgendwo
seit 2004 haben die haben allein die
Amerikaner mehr als 300 echte
interessante
UFO-Fälle registriert und zwar mit
mehreren Sensoren und so also nicht dass
da einer mal was gesehen hat haben sie
Angst davor also würde ich ja nicht
machen also
also sie glauben das sind Phänomene mit
denen sollten wir uns auseinandersetzen
wenn wir Glück haben eins da jemand gut
mit uns glaube wir müssen uns damit
auseinandersetzen Soziologen sagen wie
gesagt katastrophale Folgen wenn sich
jetzt wirklich rausstellt also nimm
lieber jetzt mal an das sind werden
jetzt wirklich außerirdische Raumschiffe
was ich nicht glaube die jetzt
abgeschossen worden sind aber nehmen wir
das mal an so die gehen jetzt in
kanadischen Territorium runter so ähm
angenommen es steckt eine
hochentwickeltechnologie dahinter so ähm
wer hat denn da kein Interesse daran
sich dieser Technologie zu bemächtigen
und einen Vorteil zu bekommen denn die
Amerikaner untersuchen ganz offiziell
angebliche
UFO Trümmerteile
als Deutschland und setzen sich mit
diesem Thema einfach auch mehr
auseinander
zum Lächeln bringt sie das in einer Art
panikmodus ist ihnen das schon zu viel
nee also ich finde es erstmal
eine gute Nachricht das ist dafür
zumindest mehr seine Quelle gibt für
diese Theorie ich glaube das ist jetzt
schon mal irgendwie eine gute Sache nee
also mich verunsichert überhaupt nicht
also ich weiß natürlich nicht der tut es
anywhere out there ich bin Kind der 90er
ich habe Akte X gesehen das hat mich
immer sehr sehr fasziniert auch wenn es
natürlich eine entertainisierung des
Themas war ich würde es mal so
formulieren aus meiner Perspektive würde
ich sagen das Weltall sie sagt gerade
keine Ahnung wo diese Wesen herkommen
wenn wir sind was auch immer das Wetter
ist auf jeden Fall so groß dass es
zumindest vermessen wäre zu glauben wir
sind die einzigen intelligente Lebewesen
in diesem Universum ob die morgen kommen
in einem Jahr in 100 Jahren weiß ich
nicht trotzdem fällt es uns schwer dann
ernsthaften Zugang zu haben also
entweder man glaubt quasi das gleiche
Tier auf der Matte steht oder man sagt
das gibt's einfach nicht es scheint
irgendwie kein zwischendrin zu geben
heute auch auf Bild aber Seite eins
UFO Krisenstab im Weißen Haus zu den
Ereignis am Wochenende da wurde
natürlich ganz klar gesagt das ist jetzt
nicht anzunehmen dennoch wird das Thema
ernst genommen müssen wir uns da ein
bisschen mehr öffnen Digger ja und das
verkauft sich natürlich wahnsinnig gut
ne das gehört auch zu weit dazu
die werden bestimmt noch ein Star mit
ihrer Geschichte auch wenn ich sie nicht
glaube aber das ist natürlich Teil des
Boulevard und das stimmt auch aber was
ich echt überhaupt nicht verstanden habe
ich glaube ich habe da entweder was
missverstanden oder Sie haben
Logikfehler sie haben gesagt dass das ja
gar nicht unbedingt UFOs sind also
Außerirdische sondern dass das
vielleicht auch eine touristische
Technik ist die dann passiert die man
aber nicht richtig erklären kann wie war
das denn gemeint sie mein Handy es gibt
ja alle möglich ich sage die werden ja
hier ständig gesehen deswegen ist es ja
eher logisch anzunehmen dass die hier
eine Basis haben als dass die jedes Mal
von ihrem was weiß ich von ceteriticuli
angeflogen kommen und dann wieder
zurückfliegen oder irgendwie sowas aber
die Frage woher die kommen das ist dann
darüber übernächste Schritt das
allererste was getan werden muss das
muss wissenschaftlich endlich auf
forscht werden das Stigma muss beendet
werden ich bin mehrfach in der
Bundespressekonferenz ausgelacht worden
weil ich diese Frage gestellt habe das
kann nicht sein wenn sie sich angucken
wie die internationale Situation ist und
es gibt in Deutschland einen Professor
an der Universität Würzburg der hat ein
internationales Forschungs für
extraterrestrik prof Hakan Kajal warum
kriegt dieser Mann der offiziell den
Auftrag hat UFOs zu erforschen warum
kriegt der keine staatlichen
Fördergelder
wann kommen wir endlich zur Berliner
Politik und drehen sich so ein bisschen
weit weg oder nicht ganz hier ich bin
natürlich ich bin natürlich auch großer
Star Wars Fan und alleine schon aufgrund
des Vornamens kann ich mich mit Luke
Skywalker natürlich identifizieren nein
ganz im Ernst ich beschäftige mich
erstmal mit den Dingen hier auf der Erde
und den Dingen die wir in Berlin
anpacken wollen das sind eine ganze
Menge
grundsätzlich ist das natürlich richtig
dass wir erstmal wieder den Blick in den
Himmel richten müssen also das glaube
ich schon als Mensch als Aufgabe wir
waren auf dem Mond das haben wir
geschafft da waren wir jetzt lange nicht
gewesen wir haben viele Planeten
drumherum und den Weltraum um uns herum
zu erforschen das ist eine
menschheitsaufgabe die wir nicht in
Berlin auch vielleicht nicht in
Deutschland aber als Europäer auf jeden
Fall angehen können der macht er die
seine ganze Menge Sachen ob
Außerirdischen jetzt schon zu uns kommen
das sage ich erstmal zu bezweifeln oder
schon da sind das glaube ich habe ich
auch ein bisschen bei Ihnen
das muss wissenschaftlich das muss
geklärt werden erforscht werden so wie
die Sache mit Nordstemmen ich treibe
mich auch auf wissenschaftskonferenzen
um die letzte Wissenschaftskonferenz hat
sich zum Beispiel gedreht darum wie
funktioniert der ufoantrieb und so also
für diese Wissenschaftler die sich auf
hohe Ebene international und da rede ich
von wirklich hochrangigen
Wissenschaftlern mit der Frage
beschäftigen ist diese Frage ob es die
gibt oder nicht schon längst abgehakt
die Frage ist was was brauchen wir also
brauchen wir mehr Investitionen in
Raumfahrttechnik brauchen wir wir
brauchen jemanden der sich das Thema ist
in der Regierung
ganz öffentliche breite Debatte über die
Folgen über dieses ganze Thema ohne dass
darüber ständig gedacht wird ja also
dieses Lachen das ist schon sowas von
übergestrich ja wir müssen das Thema
endlich ernst nehmen zweitens wir
brauchen
staatliche Forschungsgelder oder
zumindest muss möglich sein für sowas
wissenschaftliche Forschungsgeld dazu
kriegen die Wissenschaftler stehen in
den Startlöchern sie auch nicht mit wem
ich manchmal telefoniere und ich sagen
ja aber ich krieg doch sowieso keine
Forschungsgelder dafür und das ist ein
Problem und ich denke in Würzburg an der
Universität mit dem Professor Kajal
hätte die Bundesregierung einen
Supermarkt eine Person
ist ja auch der einzige der das in
Deutschland offiziell als
Wissenschaftler untersuchen darf aber er
hat kein Budget und leider kein Budget
hat kann das nicht untersuchen kann er
nicht hier ernst sein dass wir ernsthaft
unser Steuergeld benutzen sollen um
sowas zu erforschen wenn wir so viele
echte Probleme haben die Amerika wird es
als die Bedrohung der nationalen
Sicherheit gesehen sie haben gesehen
dass gerade in Amerika los war wieso
sollten das so ein abgefahrenes Thema
sein das ist ein abgefahrenes Thema
gucken Sie doch mal auf die Straße wir
haben hier Lehrermangel überall wir
haben die Rentner die verarmen wir haben
sicher ist das Auto muss modernisiert
werden wir haben den Verbrenner aus 2035
also wir müssen so viel forschen das
kostet alles teuer Geld und sie kann
doch nicht ernsthaft dann sagen wir
nehmen eine oder zwei oder drei
Milliarden da weg
von Milliarden aber sie könnten schon
mit einer Million extrem viel ausrichten
in der UFO-Forschung und ich muss sagen
gebe ich Ihnen recht es gibt natürlich
auch ganz interess ante Probleme nicht
zu knapp gerade im Moment ja